I'm this delicious but I'm just tasted
his it's absolutely fantastic can I
could I change and have that it's
terrible
do you mind okay thank you
prego what's going on
prego what's going look at your face
he's so delicious I wanted that one
instead
yeah I don't want this great I want to
have a charge things yeah that's it kind
of course yeah it's good it's good
thank you that was a disaster
have you any idea how flexible we have
to be with customers today I
deliberately put her in there to see
what level of flexibility your
restaurant gracious really really
gracious why are you coming out and
being ten times more charming than your
maitre d towards me please
well I remember I say very well they
yeah I agree with you that many things
were wrong did they fought earlier and
it's not always like that for money now
that was a bad day we will have them
bounce back and put it right you're more
capable of doing it
listen bet the first thing to though I
mean where people coming in looking oh
man you give the drink ten minutes or so
a little bit too long I mean a little
bit is too long I'm not gonna sugarcoat
it it's not a good thing
no or definitely come back from it and
you know we're a restaurant where a live
thing we you know we're growing all the
time we've only just got there and we're
doing amazing amazing work every day
every service we're doing a great job
and that's why we're still in this and
we can win this